welcome back some people are feeling
pretty good about how business is going
up at Lake Las Vegas Madison Kimbrough
gives us a peek
when I heard that they were going to do
a blue heron Lake Las Vegas Waterfront
subdivision starting just under a
million dollars I was like I've got to
check this out realtor Mason Richburg
just sold two homes in the Shoreline
Community of Lake Las Vegas these
properties built by upscale production
homebuilder Blue Heron Lake Las Vegas
it's like having a resort-like living in
Vegas Eileen Godoy Quinto ready to move
her family to the area after living in
Summerlin for several years now that she
works from home she wanted something
that she could both work in and enjoy
Family Life see it's safe it's a
community accessible to the restaurants
water sports for my kids and at the same
time you have hotel that it's a walking
distance and eco-friendly you can just
golf cart around and with the purchase
of these properties you're not just
getting a waterfront view but access to
their sports club and also water
activities out on the lake president of
Blue Heron Chris buchler shares details
about the properties they vary in square
footage from 2700 to 3 700 square feet
approximate we will be opening our
models in the next 45 days we have 20
homes already Under Construction And as
far as who is buying we've seen a lot of
influx from California The Californians
come here because they like the
lakefront living you know they they
can't get water anywhere else in in Las
Vegas so they like that we see a real
mix and what's interesting here is we're
seeing a mix of both the retirees people
who would like to work from home